les deux records les plus
extraordinaires aux échecs en 2011 le
grand maître iranien essan GEM Magami a
disputé une simultanée de 604 parties
c'est-à-dire qu'il affroné en même temps
604 adversaires jouant un coup après
l'autre le tout se déroulait dans un
stade de foot et il a quand même gagné
580 parties pour seulement 16 nuls et 8
défaites record encore plus
extraordinaire le grand maître américain
Timour gareev a lui fait une simultanée
à l'aveugle c'està-dire avec un bandeau
sur les yeux ne voyait aucune des
positions durant toutes les parties 48
en même temps avec 35 victoires 7 nuls
et 6 défaite contre une moyenne hlo
d'environ 1700 donc loin d'être facile
et comme ça ne suffisait pas il a
réalisé son exploit en pédalant sur un
vélo d'appartement tout du long